[Musique]
coeur du clunysois dedans cette
minoterie on ne chôme pas chaque jour
ici 300 tonnes de grains sont
transformés en farine
ils sont 160 salariés chauffeur livreur
opérateurs commerciaux ou responsable
d'exploitation comme béatrice de flandre
arrivé il ya quatre ans elle est ici
comme un poisson dans l'eau
ici comme toute entreprise en fin de
compte familial c'est vrai qu'on a un
rapport avec les collaborateurs qui
n'est pas le même lorsqu'on travaille
dans des grands groupes et
et de la même manière au niveau du
process la meunerie est un process à ses
anciens on va dire avec des appareils
au nettoyage du grain mouillage passage
sur cylindres au fil des siècles
le procédé n'a guère évolué en revanche
l'élaboration des farines est devenu de
plus en plus pointues ici on cherche à
répondre au mieux à la demande des
consommateurs et par conséquent à celle
des boulangers notre clientèle est basée
dans un rayon d'environ 300 400 km de
l'amiante dont on est vraiment très
proche et en plus les gens tous nos
numéros directs d'accès
on a des gens qui nous appellent en
pleine nuit parmi les 1500 clients de la
minoterie la boulangerie agnello à
beaune pierre et sa femme catherine ont
repris cette affaire il ya 14 mois
d'abord à leur compte pendant 20 ans ils
ont décidé d'être salarié l'histoire
tournera court après la faillite de leur
patron pour cette nouvelle aventure
la minoterie forêt leur a proposé bien
plus que de la farine
ils ont aidé ans approuvé licencié au
chômage
ils nous ont aidés pour tout ce qui est
administratif pour pouvoir reprendre une
affaire de la recherche du commerce le
jusqu'à signer chez notaire tout en
passant par les banques ou le grand
meunier lui on est comme un pion en fait
on un petit pion comme des numéros en
fait alors que on est vraiment pris pour
ce qu on est quoi leurs clients
entre les éloigner l'eau et la minoterie
ferait pas de contrat d'exclusivité d
une relation basée sur la confiance
règne
autre credo de ce meunier soutenir les
petits artisans tout en résistant aux
sirènes des grandes chaînes de boulanger
nos clients sont
à 90% des clients artisans boulangers et
on essaye de mettre à disposition tout
un tas d'outils de services pour les
aider à se battre face aux grandes
chaînes qui se développe c'est vrai très
vite et en 1921 dans un petit moulin sur
les bords de la grosne la minoterie
forêt est avant tout une histoire de
famille
benoît emile alain et les autres en près
d'un siècle
ils ont façonné l'entreprise aujourd'hui
la quatrième génération est aux manettes
j'ai grandi ici ce qui m'a fait partir
c'était de la volonté de voir découvrir
autre chose que la minoterie
mais ce qui m'a fait revenir c'était
l'attachement d'origine que j'avais à
l'entreprise
on a la chance d'être 4
jeunes soient frère soit cousin avec des
rôles très différents soit très terrain
soit plutôt dans la finance soit dans la
transaction
on est complémentaires
une équipe gagnante aujourd'hui cette
minoterie familiale et la 10e de france
avec un chiffre d'affaires de 35
millions d'euros
[Musique]